quant à toi salut la compagnie je le
garde le costume oui évidemment chantera
pas dedans surtout ne fais pas ce que je
ferai encore moi ce que je ne ferai
jamais de reste quand même un petit
espace dans lequel tu peux évoluer
salut les gars non mais attendez
je vais pas les vraies mesures
ça ne veut pas dire que tu n as wenger
si tu te poses la question
bon allez calme-toi je suis juste en
train de trouver la portière bazire
histoire c'est une faute bonne chance
le monde change les années il est temps
qu'on change nous aussi
ce monstre au volant
les gens qui sont là pour gérer ce genre
de choses
prennent trois gamins dit mais c'est ce
que tu es c'est l'occasion de fermer
mais pas sur ma route
ce que je te tuerais
moi et tout ce que tu aimes
[Musique]